avy you alright let's do this
you got what this year
[Music]
what now
about it Johnny
[Music]
[Music]
where are we I'll BBS data fortress
Britt's to the deep net
[Music]
Blackwall
welcome to the cyberpunk 2077 2019 deep
dive video in last year's gameplay
review we showed you our vision for the
world of cyberpunk 2077 its quests and
visual design this year we'd like to
give you a peek at some of the play
styles you'll be able to adopt as your
character progresses through the store
here goes nothing you're about to see
sequences embodying two distinct
approaches to playing cyber will show
you a strong solo build that is a
character who focuses on employing blunt
force and taking instant action
and a netrunner bid a play style taking
frequent advantage of stealth tactics
packing and battlefield control achieved
using malicious software
[Music]
additionally you'll learn more about
Pacifica one of the games districts two
gangs and the animals and the Voodoo
boys and you'll see glimpses of Johnny
silver in the digital construct who
haunts our main character
a word of caution given that the video
covers a section of the game deep into
the main storyline we have edited the
footage to contain as few spoilers as
possible be aware that the gameplay as
presented does reveal characters and
locations you'll see while playing the
game's main story are so watch at your
own discretion where we headed
[Music]
this way
[Music]
in this video you'll experience a
segment of a quest from the middle of
the game we're currently in Pacifica one
of the night cities six unique districts
nobody makes out with you guys aren't
exactly great a rolling out the welcome
mat for outsiders it was designed to be
a tourist hotspot within the city as you
can see this didn't pan out
when uncertainty struck the global
economy investors pulled their funding
leaving most establishments unfinished
it's one of those places where
expectations and reality collide
resulting in a heap of disappointing
ongoing gang wars playing this part of
the city Outsiders don't come here if
they don't have to even by night city's
standards
it's dangerous to those unfamiliar with
taking a casual stroll here would not be
a good idea a fast motorbike or
armor-plated car would be the safer
option
but places like this have their
advantages if you're in need of rare
goods or illegal cyberware Pacifica's
bustling local markets are a good place
to start your search the grand imperial
mall is a whole other story it was one
of the last developments in Pacifica to
lose its funding until recently it stood
vacant but now a game called the animals
has moved in for reasons unknown and
that's what we need to learn in order to
earn the trust of the Rue du Bois the
animals rivals what the hell could
[ __ ] tell me what you plan to do
first you take job you do what I see of
the many gangs in cyberpunk 2077 the
Voodoo boys are the most skilled at
using the net why what for this
mysterious gang of highly skilled net
runners has close ties to the local
Haitian community you RB we have been
waiting patients settled in Pacifica in
the 2060s
after natural disasters struck their
island and forced them to emigrate on
mass the Voodoo boys gang formed around
this same time though at a smaller scale
now the gang effectively rules Pacifica
the voodoo boys don't usually work with
outsiders lucky for us it seems they're
prepared to make an exception this time
mr. Hanson said you got Merc work needs
doing still to earn their trust we need
to prove our worth plac'd one of the
voodoo boys higher-ups has offered a
submission we need to infiltrate the
grand imperial mall currently occupied
by the voodoo boys deadly enemy a gang
called the animals
20850 civic three second before become
your net we try to learn where they come
your net come from the animals are not
your normal game their presence and
Pacifica is suspicious the value might
above all else and where melee combat
implants to raise their prowess in
combat their beverage of choices juice
potent strength through speed enhancing
concoction as sought-after bouncers
they're usually dispersed throughout
town as skilled street-level business
types they've cornered the market in
illegal substances and underground live
or die prize fights when they converge
in one spot it's for something big
it's then they appoint the fastest and
strongest among them as their ad-hoc
leader in this case it's a woman named
sasquatch
now far as I remember you said Gopal
frame buffaloes on their way afraid
ethnic often do a bit this is the tech
plac'd was talking about it seems
non-standard for the animals and this is
where we come in getting to the van
won't be easy but were more than
qualified for the job which we can
complete in one of many ways
[Music]
the character creation in cyberpunk 2077
is the kind you'd expect from a
full-fledged RPG you start by choosing
your past important because this unlocks
special options and important story
junctures you also fully customize your
character using a deep customization
system that spans not only your look and
style but also your abilities cyberpunk
2077 does not feature fixed classes
instead it has a fluid class system that
allows players to mix and match a wide
range of abilities to suit their play
styles you can create a strong solo
character a skilled netrunner
or any other hybrid class you can learn
[Music]
let's see how a solo play style in
cyberpunk 2077 might work solos prefer a
direct approach they use guns and might
to get these diving so let's reach
sematic with our enhanced strength we
can strip this turret of its weapons
into the animals a taste of their own
medicine this is how a player investing
in solo abilities might live out their
Terminator power fantasy enhance
strength lets us force open doors
or grab enemies to use as human shields
we also gain access to powerful melee
combat cyber light so even someone as
fast and strong as sasquatch the leader
of this group of animals is not
impossible to beat for a solo
god Sasquatch has a different game plan
she's out to Jack in and haggis let's
see how this plays out see what's going
on
it's our choice if we want to finish her
off or spare her your cyberpunk your
rules
if you'd rather sneak around hide and
strike from the shadows no problem just
develop your net running skills to get
around obstacles or hack into enemy tech
to have it do the dirty work for you
[Music]
net running abilities mean hacking
skills that let us use our cyber deck to
breach access points for this we fill
the buffer of our cyber deck with a
string of instructions represented by
these letters and numbers matching the
instructions for basic access grants us
control of devices connected to this
network the more instructions we match
the more control gained over elements in
the network we can hack our way through
in numerous ways a quick hack may grant
us control of the security camera
another one should let us tweak the
difficulty of the training bot to create
a distraction
[Music]
with our nanowire we can even hack this
guy's implants from a distance
[Music]
in this world almost everything is
connected to a local network and that
means it can be hacked which brings us
back to cyberspace you don't get to do
anything in the net unnoticed there's
always someone watching it could be core
pose or even worse it could be net watch
and that is exactly the case here who is
big net watch and the voodoo boys are
like fire and ice the first of these
wants to maintain the old order and
protect people from AI anarchy
originating from beyond the black wall
the voodoo boys want to establish
contact with the free ai's they believe
this will enable their boundless
expansion on the net and grant them the
upper hand over net watch net watch sees
this as the end of the world both are
right whoa hey how you deal with the net
watch agent is entirely up to you do we
side with the gang choosing to be on net
watches bad side is never wise but can
we really trust the Voodoo boys as you
can see we have many possible options
but in each case we take a risk think
I'll just stick to my food
[Music]
that didn't work out well in the world
of cyberpunk few things go as planned
and that was just a glimpse of how
complex the branching storyline in
cyberpunk 2077 can get every decision
you make will have consequences your
choices will shape how the world reacts
to you and affect your relationships
with those around you one of those
relationships is special ever heard of
Johnny silver ham a rebel rocker boy who
will be your companion throughout your
adventure in night city come on really
think they'd give a rat's - how you look
like everyone in cyberpunk 2077 he has
his own agenda you'll decide if he'll be
your ally or your enemy and that chip in
your head the one thanks to its Johnny
who lives inside your mind well that's a
story for another time
you